avant même qu'il ne prenne forme le
projet de communes nouvelles entre
maurepas et coignières est déjà enterré
annoncé le 9 avril dernier à la presse
il a suscité depuis de nombreux débats
notamment du côté de coignières un
projet contesté par l'opposition et des
habitants qui dénonce un manque de
consultation actuellement en
convalescence le maire de coignières
jean-pierre sevestre a confié la gestion
de la ville à son adjoint david
pelletier
vendredi 4 mai la municipalité annonce
l'arrêt du projet de communes nouvelles
avec maurepas peut-être un peu
d'incompréhension et notamment sur les
études puisqu'aujourd'hui s'agissait que
d' études il y a que des études qui ont
été présentées en conseil municipal il a
été dit que la fusion serait votée le 2
mai il en a jamais été question
donc donc voilà on peut on peut
peut-être regretter la façon mais on
souhaitait l'unanimité parce que c'est
un projet important pour la ville et
donc il était nécessaire que que tout le
monde tout le monde le ressentent ainsi
donc donc l'unanimité n'était pas là
nous nous avons préféré le retirer
et c'est une décision qui est avant tout
collective du côté de la ville de
maurepas le maire grégory gary astier a
pris acte de cette décision
maurepas qui avaient voté mercredi 2 mai
lors de son conseil municipal le
lancement d'une étude sur le projet le
conseil avait néanmoins été quelque peu
agitée pas d'identité commune donc pour
nos repas et coignières mais les deux
parties souhaitent garder de bonnes
relations
rappelons que les villes partagent déjà
plusieurs services
les archives la police municipale et
bientôt un centre aquatique